Fabi uh first of all
um not a very difficult day at the
office for you did you expect that from
Wesley did you expect this mild strategy
from him I wasn't sure I thought either
he's going to play E4 and go for uh for
a Sharp fight I thought E4 would be a
sign that he's he's going for it and D4
would be a sign that he wants to rock up
keep it solid which he sometimes tends
to do and it really depends on his mood
I think and I thought it was 50 50.
sometimes he goes for a win and he's
very dangerous and sometimes he plays
super super solid and you don't really
have any chances to win or
um because I mean he plays like super
um
like super accurate chess in general
so when he played the kettle and I
thought it's it's sort of
I'm playing a solid line I mean it's
most likely we're going to reach this
position after Bishop C6 and I wasn't
sure exactly like he played recently one
of the most topical lines so I mean he
played Bishop D2 against Anish and
Vikings a
and I felt a little bit stupid because I
couldn't remember how the game went even
though I saw it this morning
I wasn't sure if it was A5 Queen D3 or
Knight E4 here
but I thought maybe the game on A5 Queen
D3 Bishop B4 I wasn't 100 sure this was
the game it seems to have been a game of
Wesley but with the black pieces against
Shanklin
uh I'm not sure you should have done
now we're out of the game we're out of
commission so uh not much happened in
this game I mean he could have played on
it at the end I think
um after I played H5 I
I just didn't really see how to free my
pieces so I wanted to create some
counter play on the king side and I
think he could have played on like he's
he's probably a tiny bit better but it
is more or less an equal position
um I wasn't opposed to his repetition
repetition well you're the man to catch
in this tournament right now you have
some followers that's reach a report
have a point behind Wesley was one of
them but obviously he's not going to be
able to catch up with you did you manage
to see any of the other games any uh
spectacular things happening in your
opinion well an issue's game is
interesting uh against sting this is
very dangerous for black it looked like
and
I wasn't sure can we have a look at this
game all right now it's over
unfortunately it's over because I'm 100
sure how to do the uh
how to get out of where you placed us
Bobby
that's okay I can figure this
is
we will figure it out at some point but
not right now
yeah that's an interesting game I I
think I was a bit surprised by his
rookie shape move
but I was even more surprised that Anish
got like such a dangerous position like
such a such a dangerous attack like if I
move 10. did you analyze that because we
know you're an expert in the Italian as
well with white and black you play it I
haven't checked this exact position but
I mean I I also might have checked it
but forgotten I'm not sure it just
didn't really ring a bell
of course sacrifices like this are
always possible and uh
yeah I I thought that Bishop takes F2
was was a critical move after Knight F1
but I guess there's something wrong with
it I wasn't sure I thought that Rook h8
is like looking super super dangerous
what he played and I don't know what's
going on but um I do hope he survives
obviously because uh like it doesn't
really help my tournament if another
person goes on plus one yeah if on each
goes on plus one and I'm also a bit
worried about Dion's position although
that one is more or less balanced yeah
at least objectively according yeah but
it looked a bit more pleasant for white
end and Jana's a bit down on time so
of course there's positions of that but
like let's say in terms of decisive
games that could happen those are the
two that I would point to and Richie's
position looked level to me looked quite
level but anything could happen it is
double it is like let's say an
imbalanced position what are the
feelings that you experience when you've
just uh finished a long tournament or
you know that sapped into your energy
levels and then you have to play chess
once again because it seems to be
there's something that's been hitting
both Jan and and ding
from your experience
well I what can I say they're not
playing too well
Jan has solidified a bit he had this
like really rough patch where he clearly
got tilted
against me
um and and then against Maxine like this
was like very clear tilt I mean his game
against vaccine was to
put it politely completely atrocious
um it was I mean he'll tell you the same
thing that it was a really bad game he
would he was better and he just started
to shuffle his pieces
basically back and forth while Maxine
improves his position with every move so
those two games were clear tilty seems
to have uh come back come back to his
senses at least he's playing like
relatively normal chess
um ding like I don't understand his game
yesterday
you know the funny thing is the line he
played against
Wesley I was considering planning as
young because it is sort of a way to get
a fight but when I was looking at the
line it felt like it's just very healthy
for black basically you can make any
move and why it takes a great deal of
risk moving pieces back and forth like
Queen D4 Queen D1
um but like the way that he played it
just showed like a lack of feeling of
danger I mean
you
like if you compared to a king's Indian
or something which is like a typical
position from the structure you know
usually white is castled and has
everything aimed at the D5 Square here
white uh moved the queen around back and
forth and then move the knight from G1
E2 to F4 to H3 yeah and so usually you
don't want to take lost a lot of tampies
three three moves to play your knight on
H3 and black is completely developed
like it just felt feels wrong so his
play felt really bad in that game
yesterday in general his Play Feels
like something's very off yeah yeah well
thank you for that assessment Fabi will
let you get some rest before the
championship rounds tomorrow you play
Anish with the white pieces and you
finish it off with Richie report
um how are you going to approach this
of games
yeah I'll try to put pressure on it it's
not easy I usually struggled to create
winning chances against him and he's
like super
super solid uh very well prepared player
um very level-headed so
sometimes difficult to create chances
against him but I'll try and and the
last round we'll see what the tournament
situation is thank you very much Fabi
we'll see you tomorrow guys back to you
thank you Christian thank you